[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale proposée par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 17 mars voici
les titres de cette édition
c'était il ya tout juste un an la france
est les yvelines se confinait pour faire
face à l'épidémie de kobe 19 une mise en
pause qui durera deux mois au total
jusqu'au 11 mai 2020 avant un deuxième
confinement plus les gens en novembre
depuis le couvre-feu a fait également
son apparition
retour sur un an de crise sanitaire une
période difficile à vivre pour tous avec
certains secteurs particulièrement
impacté les restaurants et bars sont
toujours fermés tout comme les théâtres
salles de spectacles et les cinémas et
les étudiants également subi les
conséquences de la pandémie invités de
cette édition justement étudiants
restent au recteur et acteurs du monde
culturel et puis la crise sanitaire a vu
aussi l'émergence d'initiatives
positives des innovations dont certaines
dans les yvelines machine tueuse de
coronavirus stand stérile qui se déploie
en quelques minutes ou encore recyclage
des masques focus sur ces créations yves
hinse emmanuel macron dans les yvelines
cet après midi le président de la
république s'est rendu au centre
hospitalier de poissy saint germain en
laye pour une visite dans le service de
réanimation est aussi échanger avec les
élus et des placements dans un contexte
très tendu à l'hôpital et avec
l'hypothèse d'un reconfirme en
ile-de-france qui semble se confirmer on
retrouve sur place
astrid bergère bonsoir grigori oui comme
vous le disiez la situation en ile de
france est très tendue notamment dans
les hôpitaux
le taux d'occupation en réanimation par
des patients qu'aux vide est
actuellement 200 2,6 pour cent
emmanuel macron était donc ici à
l'hôpital de poissy saint germain en
laye pour visiter plusieurs services
sous tension notamment la réanimation et
pour rencontrer des soignants il
échangera ensuite en visioconférence
avec des maires d'île de france et
d'autres régions qui sont concernés
alors cette visite elle intervient
quelques heures après un conseil de
défense qui s'est tenue ce matin et à
l'issue de ce conseil gabriela talent
porte-parole du gouvernement a annoncé
que des mesures
supplémentaire allait bientôt être mise
en place dans la région et qu'elle
serait effective dès ce week end
ce tour de vis ce sera annoncé demain
lors d'une conférence de presse à 18h
par le premier ministre jean castex et
par le ministre de la santé et des
solidarités olivier ferrand astrid
berges hier sur place avec patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques
leur confinement en ile-de-france à
l'étude donc un an jour pour jour après
le premier confinement le 17 mars 2020
elle la france et les yvelines était
placée sous cloche douze mois plus tard
le colis 19 est toujours présent dans
nos vies
retour sur un nom de pandémie dans les
yvelines avec eléonore sinoquet nous
sommes en guerre il est midi pile nous
sommes le 17 mars 2020 la france est
officiellement confiné une situation
historique annoncée par le président de
la république la veille plus le droit de
sortir sauf pour se soigner faire ses
courses ou aller travailler
une autorisation dérogatoire de sortie
fait alors son apparition
plusieurs déplacements reste possible
mais il faudra vous munir de
l'autorisation de déplacement
dérogatoire les élèves des écoles
collèges lycées sont priés de rester
chez eux les commerces et la culture
sont à l'arrêt le 26 mars plus de 50% de
l'activité économique des yvelines et
stopper le deuxième tour des élections
municipales reporter ce ne sera que mi
avril qu emmanuel macron donne une date
pour le déconfinement le 11 mai c'est
pour cela que le confinement le plus
strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai et ce 11 mai est
enfin là les yvelinois comme tous les
français se ruent chez les coiffeurs
notamment les écoles du département
retrouve les rires des enfants avec un
protocole sanitaire renforcée le 2 juin
c'est au tour des restaurants et des
bars uniquement en terrasse en ile de
france mais c'est déjà ça
la culture retrouve aussi son public
quinze semaines après le premier le
second tour des élections municipales
est organisée le 28 juin
avec l'été vient l'accalmie mais aussi
le relâchement des gestes-barrières jour
de fête nationale
le président annonce l'obligation du
port du masque en intérieur le préfet
des yvelines jean jacques brot appliquée
mais mettant l'obligation de ce port du
masque dans les marchés brocantes et
vide-greniers
le 15 août septembre et lahi la rentrée
donc masqué dans les écoles jusqu'à 11
ans et dans les entreprises également le
département des yvelines distribuer
alors cet équipement devenu objet du
quotidien
aussi les dépistages se généraliser sur
tout s'accélère à saint quentin en
yvelines
le vélodrome nationale se transforme en
centre de dépistage du coc vide
autre mesure le 14 octobre le
gouvernement décide de placer
l'ile-de-france sous couvre-feu de 21h à
6h du matin et ce qui devait arriver
arriva le 29 octobre 2e confinement est
acté et c'est le grand retour des
attestations mais depuis quelques heures
ce n'est pas une mais trois attestations
qui sont disponibles sur le site du
gouvernement et sur l'application tous
antico vide 24 novembre un plan de
déconfinement est présenté par étapes
mais tout ne se passe pas comme prévu
quelques semaines plus tard un nouveau
couvre feu national est instauré de 20
heures à 6 heures du matin cette fois ci
seule exception le soir de noël le 24
décembre et justement fin décembre un
espoir
la campagne de vaccination commence le
31 décembre quatorze résidents de
l'ehpad mon repos de sartrouville marque
l'entrée des yvelines dans cette
campagne vaccinale mais malgré le début
de la vaccination le 16 janvier le
couvre-feu est une nouvelle fois avancé
à 18h les yvelines comme 68 autres
départements sont toujours considéré
comme zone d' alerte renforcée
les conférences de presse du
gouvernement s'enchaînent et le 22
février nice et dunkerque se retrouve
confiné le week end
mi mars l'île de france y échappe pour
le moment mais pour combien de temps
encore et avec nous tout au long de
cette édition spéciale des invités en
plateau le premier d'entre eux gaëtan
mal honda bonsoir bonsoir à vous vous
êtes restaurateur pro pierre
propriétaire de l'atelier 2 et gaëtan
c'est une crêperie qui est installé à
juziers alors les bars et restaurants
sont fermés
désormais depuis fin octobre avec une
année très particulière pour pour ce
monde de la restauration un premier
confinement une réouverture début juin
puis un couvre feu mis en place qui vous
a contraint à fermer boutique plutôt
avant une fermeture pure et simple de la
restauration sur place
comment vous avez vécu cette année
personnellement mais aussi en tant que
restaurateur justement alors cette
première année de confinement a été très
particulière parce qu'il a fallu se
réinventer il a fallu trouver des des
nouvelles choses à mettre en place à
faire sans le sang le personnel parce
que maintenant je travaille
principalement tout seul donc dire mais
de salariés on est 80 ou huit on est 80
ou émanant principalement je travaille
tout seul dans la cuisine et voilà il a
fallu serait se réinventer comme on peut
une année difficile et de réadaptation
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
tout à l'heure vous estimiez octobre une
perte de 100 mille euros sur l'année
2020 ça veut dire en 2021 avec peut-être
plus deux mois de fermeture encore ce
pourrait être encore plus élevé bannon
servette
oui ça pourrait être encore plus élevé
parce qu'on est fermée encore depuis le
mois de novembre ça continue je pense
que vu les annonces qui sont prévues
demain ça va continuer on n'est pas prêt
d'ouvrir et je pense lui que la perte de
chiffre d'affaires peut être un peu plus
importante sur ce bilan qui arrive une
fois de plus quoi confinement possible
annoncer demain on en saura plus au
cours d'une conférence de presse demain
il ya des aides de l'état qui ont été
tout de même mise en place
le chômage partiel notamment les l'epg
aussi les prêts garantis par l'état ce
que vous avez eu recours à ces aides
oui oui nous avons pris soixante quinze
mille euros de prêts garantis par l'état
donc c'est encore une fausse aide si on
si on peut dire parce que c'est encore
un prêt qui vient sur la société sur
l'endettement de la société
mais il n'y avait pas le choix pour la
pérennité de l'entreprise s'était
totalement vital il vous ai commencé à
le rembourser vers grand-air encore pas
encore on en n'a pu faire encore un
différé d'un an
on commencera à partir de mai 2022 des
perspectives qui ne sont pas forcément
bonnes pas de date de réouverture à ce
jour évoquées même si une rencontre a eu
lieu hier entre l1 les ânes ministre
délégué en charge des petites et
moyennes entreprises et les
organisations patronales du secteur avec
un plan de réouverture qui a été évoqué
en trois phases et notamment
l'application toujours de secours au
protocole sanitaire renforcée mais qui
serait encore complétée d'un dispositif
de traçage de la clientèle au moyen de
qr code sur le téléphone
dit comme ça ça semble difficile à
mettre en place ça semble très difficile
parce qu'on est et restaurateurs on
n'est pas nous sommes pas médecins nous
sommes pas policier nous sommes
restaurateurs c'est la base de notre
métier et c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà
énormément de protocole à mettre en
place et si en plus maintenant il
nourrit nous ajoute encore plus de
choses ça va être très très compliqué il
n'y a plus de plaisir à venir manger
chez chez son restaurateur
une dernière question vous parliez tout
à l'heure d'une manière de se réinventer
en cette crise sanitaire on imagine la
vente à emporter vous l'avez mise en
place est ce que vous avez mis en place
de nouveaux processus aussi oui nous
devons continuer à travailler
oui nous avons mis en place dix
possibles de plateaux repas tous les
midis choses qu'on ne qu'on ne faisait
pas avant
qui fonctionne pas trop mal donc tirent
des petits plateaux repas entrée plat
dessert pour la clientèle qui sur les
alentours la vente en compte est ce que
votre clientèle de base et est au rendez
vous et ce qu'elle continue de vous
soutenir
aujourd'hui la la clientèle est bien
présente ils sont tous là ça nous fait
plaisir quand même il ya le site
internet de rester ensemble qui
s'affiche tout ce que vous faites partie
de cette association qui ont fait le
premier restaurateur
ça permet d'échanger de se serrer les
coudes de pouvoir avoir d'autres infos
d'autres d'autres collègues et surtout
de bip de d'être soudés donc souhaite
bon courage en tout cas servi dans la
suite de cette crise a été remerciée
vous à gaëtan malon daj rappelle que
vous êtes propriétaire de l'atelier de
gaëtan c'est une crêperie et qui est
installée dans la commune de jausiers la
crise sanitaire a eu aussi fort
heureusement quelques conséquences
positives a été l'accélérateur
d'innovation et notamment dans les
yvelines est des entreprises ont inventé
des concepts novateurs pour lutter à
leur manière contre l'épidémie
retour sur quatre créations yvelinoise
avec eléonore sinoquet si la crise
sanitaire a changé nos habitudes elle
permet aussi de développer la créativité
de certains entreprises ou particuliers
ont innové depuis un an
c'est le cas d'un jeune étudiant
guyancourt toile et au merlot grâce à
son imprimante 3d il a créé des poignées
de portes antico vide
au lieu d'utiliser sa main pour ouvrir
la porte on utilise désormais son bras
dès la rentrée de septembre 2020 les
écoles de guyancourt en ont été équipés
un nouveau moyen de ne pas se contaminer
en plus des gestes barrières
quelques mois plus tard c'est à fontenay
le fleury qu'une nouvelle innovation
voit le jour l'entreprise piot drones
invente une machine tueuse de co vide
grâce à la technologie des uv ces deux
dispositifs l'un désinfecte les pièces
le second se charge des petits objets
une technologie intéressante mais qui
nécessite des précautions les uvc à
hautes doses peuvent être dangereux pour
l'homme
toujours dans les yvelines attrape ou la
start up here captifs utilise la
technologie des voiles de surf pour
créer une tante ultralégère déployables
n'importe où en 40 minutes et surtout
stérile une innovation conçue en huit
jours avec l' expertise d'atmosphère
contrôlée du groupe aura nos de saint
quentin en yvelines
surnommé l attente qu vide elle a pour
objectif d'accueillir des patients
positifs ou encore de monter très
rapidement un centre de dépistage ce fut
le cas sur l'autoroute a13
après les fêtes de fin d'année autre
innovation et pas des moindres
l'entreprise rick norrec situé à plaisir
à trouver une solution pour répondre à
la problématique du recyclage des
masques cet accessoire qu'il est
désormais obligatoire de porter partout
dans les yvelines en extérieur comme en
intérieur et laisser deux semaines à
température ambiante pour des
contaminations
une expérimentation de ce recyclage
novateur a été lancée avec la mairie de
plaisir pendant trois mois on parlait
tout à l'heure de la fermeture des bars
et restaurants aujourd'hui encore les
universités n'ont pas rouvert totalement
également les établissements peuvent
accueillir actuellement partiellement
leurs étudiants on parle de ce sujet des
universités avec julie le chama nouvel
invité bonsoir à vous êtes étudiante en
droit et anglais à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin élus du conseil
d'administration représentant d'un
terrasse aux uvs qu déjà comment vous
avez vous vécu cette année de crise
sanitaire comment les étudiants en
général dont il vécut entre cours à
distance passage de partiels également à
distance comment ça s'est passé
c'était effectivement une année
extrêmement difficile pour les étudiants
qui l'ont vécue très durement avec
parfois l'impression d'être les seuls
confiné souvent leurs parents des
interactions
de leur emploi les petits frères et
soeurs ont la chance d'aller au lycée au
collège
les étudiants ont l'impression d'être
très marginalisée pendant cette
technique d'être peut-être sacrifier les
sacrifiés de cette crise sanitaire
oui d'autant qu'ils étaient très souvent
exclues de la communication
gouvernementale ça a été dur à vivre
aussi
non non non la crise tarde aussi creusé
les inégalités beaucoup moins de petits
boulots également pour les étudiants
pourtant ô combien important on le sait
un dans les études
si bien que la précarité étudiante a
augmenté on conserve aujourd'hui qu'il
ya 20 % des étudiants à qui vivraient
sous le seuil de pauvreté est ce que ce
constat de l'augmentation de la
précarité étudiante vous le constater
ici à l'université versailles saint
quentin
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que la
précarité s'est grandement accrue après
il ya des initiatives qui ont été mises
en place pour tenter de contrer ce
phénomène je pense aux épiceries
solidaires l'agora et ce n'est pas assez
oui mais c'était le maximum qu'on puisse
faire l'université a prêté du matériel
financé l'achat de matériel malgré tout
il ya énormément d'étudiants qui sont
aussi dans une situation financière bien
plus compliqué on imagine vous parlez de
la gloire et l'agora et cette épicerie
sociale et solidaire qui est ouverte qui
est gérée par la fédération justement
intéressant iv sql permet aux étudiants
d'accéder à des produits alimentaires
hygiénique avec un rabais de 20% sur sur
le prix du marché
le nombre de bénéficiaires il a augmenté
de d'étudiants qui fréquentent justement
l'agora rice oui il a fallu revoir les
critères car ça se fait sur dossier
il ya plus de bénéficiaires mais il ya
aussi plus de demandes donc on a vu une
multiplication au syded par des des
associations l'association cocchiola on
ne les laisseraient leur également été
aussi des entreprises privées je pense à
picard qui a effectué des dons aux
bénéfices et la mort est donc la
solidarité s'est organisée
il est aussi des mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement emmanuel macron l'avait
fait lors d'un déplacement justement
université paris saclay des repas dans
les restaurants universitaires à 1 euro
mise en place également des chèques
si pour accéder à des consultations
c'étaient des mesures attendues est ce
qu'elle allait assez loin votre avis
peut-être fallait-il les compléter alors
c'est bien mais non ce n'est pas assez
les repas 1 euro par exemple de
bénéficie qu'aux étudiants qui se situe
à proximité des crous donc marginalise
qui habite plus loin potentiellement
ceux qui sont encore plus impactés
financièrement l'échec si pareille trois
consultations que fait-on en trois
consultations est ce qu'on résout le mal
être étudiant qui s'est développé ces
derniers mois ça me semble peu l'aspect
psychologique est très important vous le
disiez tout à l'heure les étudiants eu
le sentiment d'être les seuls confiné de
parfois se retrouver seul dans ce
confinement
bien sûr les services de santé
universitaire sont débordés les
psychologues on ne sont plus en capacité
de gérer tous les appels qu'elles
reçoivent
qu'est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
de retourner déjà l'université peut être
eh bien on a vu lors de la rentrée de
septembre que ça pouvait se faire
l'université n'est pas devenu un cluster
géant contrairement à ce qui semblait
être attendu maintenant on voit que
certains enseignements de certains
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
sont déjà en présentiel je pense aux
classes préparatoires je pense au bts
je pense que rien ne justifie le fait
que l'université ne le soit pas merci
jeudi le tchad est repassé en plateau
élus du conseil d'administration de
l'université versailles saint quentin
représentante de 1 terrasse aux uv est
ce qu est la culture également à l une
des grandes perdantes depuis maintenant
un an entre confinement déconfinement et
couvre feu les artistes sont pas
beaucoup monté sur scène au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on cherche à
s'adapter malgré tout et et à vivre
aussi le reportage de sediag à 200 go
depuis un an la crise sanitaire a
bouleversé le domaine de la culture le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines est
fermé depuis le 1er novembre pour le
public mais la vie continue à
l'extérieur du théâtre
les artistes mène des ateliers dans les
écoles mais aussi en milieu hospitalier
c'était 15 jours de présence d'une
équipe artistique de la chorégraphe
béatrice massa à l'hôpital pédiatrique
de bullion ou la s adresse aussi bien
aux personnels enfin d'abord aux
patients aux jeunes patients il ya cent
selon dix jeunes patients entre deux et
dix huit ans mais aussi du personnel
encadrant
début avril la tournée du spectacle au
nom du père d'ahmed madani sera
représenté 18 fois dans des collèges et
lycées de rambouillet poissy ou encore
guyancourt à l'intérieur du théâtre les
artistes continuent eux aussi à
travailler cette semaine
spectacle variété inspiré de discorama
une émission télé des années 60 devait
être joué il sera finalement film est
plutôt que de faire une captation
classique d'en faire un film un film de
théâtre donc on va filmer la pièce mais
aussi d'autres choses un peu autour de
la pièce et on va faire un genre de film
de cette pièce voilà parce que je
trouvais important que ce soit aussi une
création que ce soit pas seulement
filmer la pièce telle qu'elle est mais
que nous on se remette au travail et
qu'on puisse inventer des choses
nouvelles
deux nouvelles adaptations aussi pour
les théâtres qui doivent trouver des
solutions comme les live où les
captations pour pouvoir garder un lien
avec les spectateurs
cette période là nous aura appris aussi
être extrêmement réactif et à travailler
sûr sûr sûr sûr ces captations l'a
peut-être une dimension qui manquait au
théâtre mais qui ne peut être qu'une
dimension complémentaire
cette rencontre réelle entre entre le
public et les artistes
contrairement au public les
programmateurs et professionnels de la
profession peuvent toujours assister aux
représentations en physique l'été
culturel 2021 sera l'occasion de
préparer des retrouvailles avec le
public
hors les murs du théâtre et j'accueille
christophe leray en plateau bonsoir on
sort d'être scénographe professionnels
président de la troupe du crâne d'une
compagnie saint-quentinoise pour parler
avec vous de culture en ces temps de
d'épidémie déjà mêmes qui sont pour les
précédents invités comment vous l'avez
vécu vous cette année de crise sanitaire
avec ce premier confinement qui avait
débuté il ya tout juste un an
une année éprouvante en dents de scie
avec l'impression véritablement d'un
d'un gâchis parce que quelque part on
sent un an plus tard que la culture est
toujours sacrifié et donc on peut être
que solidaires de beaucoup de corps de
métier qui souffrent beaucoup en ce
moment oui la culture justement ça a été
une année de souffrance entre
confinement déconfinement jauge de
spectateurs dans les salles de
spectacles des des cinémas également
vous le disiez l'une des grandes sa
greffière je vous donne juste ce chiffre
dans l'union européenne le monde de la
culture a perdu 200 milliards d'euros
sur sur les dernières années 2020 il ya
aussi forcément on pense à des erreurs
de communication la culture non
essentiel en tout cas c'est dans cette
catégorie de commerce là qui avait été
classé les librairies
il ya eu il ya eu des erreurs
c'est plus qu'une erreur en fait c'est
un choix politique qui est qu'il a été
très clair et qui est dramatique parce
que cette cette culture française en
tout cas on la présente comme une
exception en tout cas la france a une
identité culturelle très forte c'est un
un aimant aussi qui permet aussi d'avoir
une vraie activité touristique un
dynamisme
c'est aussi un secteur économique à part
entière et d'être avec ce genre de
discours complètement maladroit et même
blessants de stigmatiser justement les
personnes entre non-essentiels essentiel
là on est vraiment sur la ligne red et
et on exacerbe aussi quelque part les
colères et cette colère est toujours par
tomber donc là on vous suit
régulièrement qui te pleurer sur tébéo
soir 18 on vous doit notamment les
scènes de compte du château de breteuil
comment à quoi a ressemblé pardon cette
année professionnellement parlant
comment vous avez pu travailler cette
année ça a été une année d'adaptation
j'ai effectivement au début du mois de
mars
j'avais une année remplie de divers
contrats moi je suis en micro entreprise
j'ai perdu à deux reprises tous mes
contrats dans l'année en mars et en
octobre
donc il a fallu redémarre chez retrouver
des contrats ils ont été possible parce
qu'il a fallu multiplier les
collaborations et puis surtout est très
polyvalent donc quand on parle de se
réinventer de se réadapter le monde de
la culture n'a fait que ça et mais avec
des mesurettes où l'on fait trois pas en
avant 4 pas en arrière c'est très
difficile de se projeter donc on a fait
de la visite en extérieur on a créé des
spectacles aussi en extérieur on a fait
du hors les murs on a fait de la visite
de monuments numérique
on a fait énormément de choses justement
je crois qu'on peut pas être plus dans
l'adaptation que ce qu'on a été tout au
long de l'année 2020 et les perspectives
sont difficiles à prévoir quand on sait
on ne sait pas même une date de
réouverture justement pour les salles de
spectacle et cinémas les théâtres à
l'instar des restaurants on parle du
deuxième trimestre 2021 mais pas de date
encore affirmé l'ajustement il y a
beaucoup de projets qui sont en cours on
passe on passe notre temps à concevoir
des projets heureusement et ça c'est
plutôt un bon signe
la confiance des différents partenaires
des monuments historiques notamment avec
qui je travaille beaucoup en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines
notamment et bien est réelle et elle est
toujours présente donc on nous demande
on nous sollicite pour trouver des idées
des idées originales qui est de concept
pour valoriser les sites de manière
aussi à être corona compatible donc ça
c'est à chaque fois des enjeux intégrer
les normes sanitaires
donc ça on le fait
les idées sont là les projets sont là
maintenant effectivement les
perspectives ça on est vraiment
tributaires de décisions auxquelles ont
malheureusement on ne peut rien faire
nous de notre côté donc on attend et
d'un caisson au delà justement de toutes
ces fermetures toutes ces annulations
le plus difficile finalement est-ce que
c'est pas le lien qui rompit aussi avec
le public
mais évidemment monde justement la
culture c'est le lien scellé change
c'est l'enrichissement de soi à travers
aussi la découverte des autres d'autres
cultures c'est le partage c'est le
dialogue c'est la confrontation parfois
j'ai failli venir avec une peau d'âne
sur la tête j'y ai pensé mais pas de
manière aussi trash peut-être mais le
fond le fond du discours elle a donc
effectivement on a les idées
maintenant on a de retrouver le public
on l'a retrouvé tout au long de l'année
2020 avec des visières avec des masques
on a répété avec la troupe du crâne en
masque j'ai joué avec aline francisco vu
juste dû au diapason avec la visière et
les perruques et les costumes d'époque
bon on a fait tout ça
on a été dans les écoles aussi on a fait
le hors les murs on a joué le jeu
maintenant j'ai par exemple mené cette
année j'ai eu quatre projets
d'expositions trois dans des monuments
historiques
1 dans une mairie c'est la seule
exposition qui a pu avoir lieu
elle a attiré 10 mille personnes en
trois semaines on était à plus tôt en
ile de france tandis que les expositions
dans les monuments étaient fermés
cette exposition qui a eu lieu au mois
de décembre a pu avoir lieu parce
qu'elle était dans une mairie et pour
autant les gestes barrières étaient
respectées donc là on a eu des
incohérences et c'est le témoignage
d'une incohérence flagrante puisque ce
protocole sanitaire on aurait très bien
pu être adaptées aussi pour les
monuments
merci à christophe leray social voyage
scénographe professionnels et président
de la troupe du crâne une éthique manie
saint-quentinoise avant de vous laisser
parlons sport le sport justement avec ce
premier confinement du printemps 2020
qui a marqué un tournant depuis une
année entre reprise des entraînements
arrêt des compétitions espoir est de
retrouver au plus vite possible des
conditions normales pour pratiquer que
ce soit aussi bien pour la pratique
individuelle d'ailleurs que la pratique
collective toutes les associations
sportives ont également suivi cette
crise sanitaire bixente n'a rien senti
steban paralysé avec l' annonce du
premier confinement le sport est
pourtant restée au coeur des centres
d'intérêts cloisonné chez eux de
nombreuses yvelinois ont pratiqué la
course à pied la musculation le fitness
certains même se sont lancés deux plus
grands défis comme courir un marathon
dans leur jardin pour les sports en club
de déconfinement n'aura pas empêché
l'arrêt des saisons annoncé le 25 mai
2020 un soulagement pour certains une
frustration pour d'autres qui n'iront
pas au bout de leur objectif
une semaine avant on était deuxième on a
perdu le dernier match qu'ils ont faite
nous nous qu'en diront nous laisse en
fait on en nationale 2 pour la saison
prochaine car les compétitions où était
à compter du 12 mars ont été
complètement interrompue et
on a comme on dit repris le solde à ce
moment là donc ça a été un peu
surprenant les saisons en cours du sport
amateur ont été annulés aux raccourcis
avec l'espoir de reprendre normalement
septembre une fois l'été passé pour les
professionnels certains événements
majeurs ont été décalées comme le tour
de france dont la dernière étape est
parti de mantes la jolie le 21 septembre
2020 on avait été frustré de pas avoir
de vélo pendant la période du gros
navires us et du gouvenement donc un
grand plaisir temps plusieurs doigts
mais l'événement comme ça je vais vous
laisser planer un beau symbole pour les
précieux aujourd'hui
mais les réjouissances sont de courte
durée avec la seconde vague de
l'épidémie et l'instauration du
couvre-feu à 21h les clubs sont obligés
de se réorganiser pas de vestiaires pas
de contact le respect obligatoire des
gestes barrières
le 2 novembre le couperet tombe le sport
est de nouveau à l'arrêt après
l'annnonce du second confinement des
centaines de sportifs de haut niveau
sont cependant sélectionnés pour pouvoir
continuer de s'entraîner pendant le
premier confinement du mois de mars en
fait les enfants ont continué à faire du
travail physique chez eux
mais malgré tout ils ont quand même
beaucoup perdu et on a mis du temps à
retrouver un niveau correct donc la
halle avantage c'est que les
entraînements se poursuivent donc il ya
moins de pertes
une fois n'est pas coutume le
déconfinement permet ensuite au club de
reprendre les entraînements en janvier
2021 des horaires aménagés étant donné
le couvre-feu donné à 18h ainsi que le
respect du protocole sanitaire un moyen
de se retrouver entre coéquipiers à
l'image du club de football de jouer en
josas le groupe l'ambiance tout ça ça
manque ça manque beaucoup
on va devoir les amis tout est fermé et
donc forcément de se retrouver comme ça
le dimanche c'est top ça fait du bien
déjà de retrouver les copains de
retrouver l'esprit d'équipé faire un
petit peu l'activité physique et
sportive en collectivité parce que faire
tout seul pendant confinement s'est pas
forcément très agréable
alors que nous nous rappelons
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire de
ce qui bouscule à la pratique de toute
activité de tout événement au groupe et
en communauté le sport comme la culture
ou les loisirs reste un an plus tard
dans la tente de pouvoir reprendre
normalement
la fédération de rugby a déjà fait le
choix d'annuler les saisons en cours
pour les amateurs d'autres sports se
joindront probablement bientôt à cette
décision
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de votre fidélité belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]